foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
because I heard you drop a fork did you
just drop a fork that's finger God
F5 F5 Finger of God twister two is real
twist excuse me Twisters no no I think
it's going to be called twist two two
windy
what do you think twist two two windy or
how about two twists are too windy
what do you think
or hear me out
twister three Tokyo
breathe twist Tokyo twist Tokyo twist
there it is Boom come on is Bill Paxton
gonna be in this
who's in this
dhcgi Bill Paxton
you're kidding but this is for you they
couldn't have put his face on the
Twister he is the Twister
I'd rather watch this guy eat humans
I can't believe it you tweet Bessie was
taunting me on Twitter about it too
coming soon to a theater near you Bill
Harding stopped a twister in 1996 but
now after 20 years no shut up no no
after 20 years he has been studying
Twisters to the point where he is now
become one Bill Paxton is Twisters here
hold on hold on hold on
here you go
[Music]
there you go go ahead now you can do it
Dr Bill Harding
saved the world from a twister in 1996
perfect see now years later in the year
2022
we he needs to save us from himself
I got twisters
[Music]
Mr two Let's Twist Again
[Laughter]
October 23rd 2023 we feel the Winds of
Change
this is perfect actually
Helen Hunt
from legendary director Jan de Bond
and introducing fatty lizzo boom boom
as
as the cow
Bill Paxton Helen Hunt
Davidson oh wow that's a big twister
twister of faith
you're welcome you're free that one's
free that one this is why they want us
to monetize Pepsi because we're doing
the job better than them
this is why my main Channel just got
demonetized because they fear that we
will do their job better than them at at
a quarter of the rate this is why they
hold me down because I have all the
skill and talent but I just I won't I
won't kill the baby for Malik I just
won't do it I don't wanna babies are
cute
oh [ __ ]
I love this I can't I can't that was
awesome I was very funny guys thank you
you know what I'm gonna do [ __ ] hey
taper you're watching clip that but I
need I don't want a regular thumbnail
I want like make it look like an
official Twister 2 trailer okay
re-edit it someone re-edit it as a
trailer
yeah well um that would be well I mean I
I had the trailer playing
um whatever figure it out
this is by the way oh my God oh my God
oh my God I was so tempted to go are you
ready are you ready are you ready
here and then there would be trailer
core like this somebody you're sitting
in the chat I'll give you credit in a
second follow the mosque of all down to
go listening to the winds change
oh my God Frozen that No One's Gonna Be
Frozen hold on if this is what it sounds
like what I think it's gonna sound like
nobody's gonna beat you hold on hold on
hold on
here we go
it's got to start with the Warner
Brothers okay here we go
um
okay here we go hold on
[Music]
come on everybody
[Music]
[Laughter]
are you supposed
is the video not playing yeah videos oh
you want to know why because OBS sucks
five dicks
this summer Bill Harding is back but
this twister is striking down on a
spring beach party
uh how about this
um Bill Paxton Chevy Chase Dan Aykroyd
how about this hear me here John Candy
who else is the Bill Murray who else was
the Harold Ramis
just said that Circle
let's see John Jim Belushi
[Music]
this is too slow
[ __ ] weird I love did you know
there's an entire community that just
does reverbs
yeah yeah oh yeah we have a channel I
have a channel that does that yeah
wow that's a love story
one man the only thing in between them
was the wind
but not a wind you've ever seen
Helen Hunt in I'm probably a lesbian but
I need the paycheck
She's a Lesbian right he was a lonely
scientist she was a devastating tornado
wait no he's well on a second their love
could never be dating the tornado
I'm in Bill Paxton in I'm in love with a
twister
uh I might see something
which reminds me of this by the way here
you go get under guy
it's hailing really bad right now we got
twister you see you see a twister dude
see that twister you remember this oh my
God
hello I'm gonna bring the video
well the video I'm actually usually want
to do the video is going to be I'll do
the Twister trailer with it here you go
yeah here you go tornado
all right it's it's really bad right now
we got twister you see that twister do
you see that twister oh my God
hello
yeah I'm getting under the tornado right
over house it's a tornado
I'm getting it off
I'm getting it I'm inside mom I gotta go
I'm gonna show the door and try to lock
out it's right above us Monster it's
humongous it's hailing golf balls
golf balls
this is horrible okay
I'm going I'm staying in okay
all right bye
here it comes here it comes it's coming
very soon right now we're in heffield
Pennsylvania March 23rd 2011.
This Tornado we don't get tornadoes here
this tornado right here it's coming hard
it's coming down hard it is right above
us do you see that do you see that
oh my God it's it's ripping stuff apart
this is a tornado guys this is a tornado
oh my God if you could see that oh my
God it landed oh my God tornado tornado
[Laughter]
you guys remember that clip
yes
I love it I also Royce one more showings
Philip Seymour Hoffman was in that I
forgot yeah he was the guy who dropped
the fork and said F5 Finger of God yeah
no come on serious okay okay
[Music]
yeah
I roll like a record baby
that's a good one all right let's see
let's see what happens
[Music]
[Music]
yes yes
we found it we found it guys
[Music]
stop myself
this is so good guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
God
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
come on
the fly
get out of here damn no one's doing that
no one could do that like us nobody
ah
that was [ __ ] perfect right
when the Twister came up on the screen
was awesome
oh [ __ ]
who found that so that song was perfect
who found that
oh gross is putting his hand up Frozen
you found that okay yes sir
it's good that was [ __ ] awesome
first off if they don't actually use
that and they twister they're idiots
right like that was perfect it was
perfect